I want to go at Reggie a little bit he
talks about he's never seen a guy like
wi beond yes you have his name is Boo
think let let me let me finish my point
they both black or something no let me
finish my point wi be is just way more
consistent than boo but boo is
person first of all that's
no is way way way way way way more
consistent than than b he's only played
three games no he's talking about over
his his French league and all you
comparing W Yama to boo bbo is the first
s foot four guy that we've seen come out
with the handle shoot the thre yes y act
y acting like y ain't never seen a guy
like that before B's the first guy
that's all I'm and I stand on what I say
you can y bro you can yell all you want
I stand on what I yell to I'm I'm
standing on what I'm saying well you
stand and Kenny and Ernie agrees with
me lack of just don't play hard that's
all yeah but I'm just noticing
everything I just realized that what
Shaq's cup says but first of
all look at his cup can you get a
closeup on this I don't know talking
where's all these things that I have
never seen before like pop it up I have
four rings what about really going to
compare boo to women young bbo is the
first big guy with that seven4 with
handles that can shoot the three passing
ability y'all act like y'all ain't never
seen no I didn't say no no I didn't say
like seen the first time I play like 74
I said I said 74s didn't dribble like
this kid if he was playing in this era
he would dribble you don't know that
stop because in our era he was doing
regular Crossovers and that the first
guy let me just say something I will say
Shaq I did like his PCT because there's
two problems I had with him in the first
half number one he's really lack a deaco
you see those little passes they might
work over in the French league they're
not going to work in the United States
cu the guys are too good he got to quit
you got to be aggressive when you make
pass out of double team and Shaq had a
great point I mean other that other
point by bu b i don't agree with that at
all when they had Eric Garden on him he
didn't like just go in the lane and just
you S4 75 just stand there you can't let
Eric Gordon cuz they ran a play and took
him back out to the three-point line you
cannot let little guys guard you